all right halloween it is uh right
around the corner here of this weekend
of course it's fun it's hectic full of
scary costumes and sweet treats yes and
awesome awesome awesome yeah but our
pets they can get very confused and kind
of out of sorts during a holiday like
halloween so keeping them calm and safe
is so important so they can enjoy as
well
sherry talk to a local veterinarian for
some advice and and you have a a guest
with you helping hands well you know i
think we get really caught up in the
chaos and maybe we don't think about how
our four-legged family members may not
look forward to the festivities the way
we do
i spoke with dr nina suzuki of desert
shores animal hospital who says there
are some big scares to keep in mind
i think are the costumes
so the scary costumes uh i remember one
time when my when i dressed up as a
devil and uh my cat looked at me and
peed all over the floor i mean these
these animals really do can get very
scared
and i can sure see why so if you like
sharing in the costume fun with your
household critters and dressing them up
too dr suzuki says make sure to keep
your pet comfortable while they're
dressed up
a lot of people dress up their pets for
halloween
that's fine just watch out for
overheating
because these pets their costumes can be
rather thick and warm and we keep them
on and then we walk around the
neighborhood hopefully it's going to be
a chilly night on sunday night just be
aware is this pet over is it panting too
much
take that costume off give them a
breather
well of course eating sweet treats meant
for people is a no-no with chocolate
being toxic for dogs and dr suzuki says
candy wrappers even decorations often
get scarfed by pets which can lead to
vomiting diarrhea and sometimes even
take surgery to remove those from their
intestines but dr suzuki says the
dreaded doorbell is the biggest
emotional trigger ding dong now fido
fluffy usually there goes barking at the
door or runs and that can be really
traumatizing all night long dr suzuki
says it's safest to put your pad in a
locked bedroom or bathroom with the tv
or radio on and their favorite toys to
keep them entertained so everybody think
about
them
while we're getting ready to have fun
the puppies of the world yeah i i like
your the the third edition of the
weather wall yes to the weather
center teammates we're taking this
costume off i promise
6 40